in this video you're going to learn how
to tell whether an equation has symmetry
with the x-axis y-axis or origin it
could be one two all three or none of
them and we're to go through three
examples to help you understand this
concept so these are called algebraic
tests and what you can do is you can
make some substitutions so if you were
to replace X in the equation with X and
Y with negative Y and when you simplify
if you get the original equation back
that tells us that the graph is going to
be symmetric about the x-axis meaning if
you fold it over that x axis it's going
to match with itself a perfect match for
the y axis symmetry the test is you
replace X with negative x and you leave
the y is the same and if you get the
original equation back its symmetric
with respect to the Y and then the
origin you replace X with negative X Y
with negative Y and if you get back to
the original then it's going to be
symmetric about the origin again it
could be more than one so you're gonna
want to test all three now if you get
stuck sometimes it helps to look at some
basic equations like y equals x squared
x equals y squared and y equals x cubed
so for example here we can see that this
is symmetric about the y-axis right if
we fold it over this it matches with
itself and notice here if I replace X
with negative x a negative x the
quantity squared gives you the same
thing x squared and y replace with Y see
how we're getting that original equation
back x equals y squared is a reflection
over the x-axis here you can see if you
replace Y with negative Y and square it
that's going to give you a positive Y
squared X stays X you can see you get
back to the original equation and y
equals x cubed is a rotation a 180
degree turn about the origin see if you
put your finger here and turn it it will
match perfectly and here what we're
doing is replacing X with negative x Y
with negative Y and when you simplify
that you'll get back to your original
equation so diving into the three
examples what do you think for number
one well let's start with x-axis
symmetry so if we replace Y with
negative Y and we replace X with just X
does that look like the original
equation well you can rearrange it by
multiplying through by negative 1 just
to get Y by itself
well when you look at this you say hmm
is this the same as the original here no
you can see these signs are actually the
opposite so we know it's not symmetric
with the x-axis let's do the y-axis test
okay so here we're replacing Y with y
and X with X and when you do that
substitution you want to put X the
negative X in parenthesis you want to
treat it like a group so here you can
see a negative times a negative times a
negative six times right that's going to
give us a positive x to the sixth same
thing here a negative between even power
that's going to be positive and it looks
like we're getting the exact same
equation so you can see it is symmetric
with respect to the y-axis okay and so
now let's just see so we'll just write Y
and then for the origin we're gonna make
them both negative so we replace Y with
negative Y X with negative x and let's
see if we get the original back well
let's see this one we know is going to
be positive X to the sixth positive x to
the fourth and negative Y if we multiply
through by negative one again to get
that Y by itself you can see we're not
getting the original equation so it
looks like it's just y-axis symmetry in
this case okay number two see if you can
do this one y equals two times X to the
fifth minus X now of course you if you
have a graphing calculator you can
always graph these and you can see you
know is it symmetric with respect to the
XY or origin or maybe two or three of
those the other way you can do it if
course is doing the test but sometimes
students forget like which test do I use
so another way to remember these tests
here is start off with your basic point
X comma Y if you reflect it over the x
axis see how we're still going right X
but now we're going down Y see the
negative Y so this is our test here for
the symmetric about the x-axis if we
reflect it over the y axis see instead
of going right X we're going left AXI
the opposite of X but we're going up the
same height the same y value so that's
our test for the y axis symmetry and
then the origin they were rotating it
180 degrees about the origin it's like a
half turn and so here you can see what's
happening is we're going instead of
right X or going left X instead of going
up Y we're going down Y so you
see both the X and the y values are the
opposite sign so sometimes this graph
here this picture here can kind of help
you remember the test but for number two
let's go ahead and start with x-axis
symmetry so I'm going to do is I'm going
to replace Y with negative Y and X is
going to remain the same if I multiply
through by negative one does this look
like the original equation no you can
see the signs of the opposite so it's
not symmetric with respect to the X how
about the y-axis
well the y-axis now what we're going to
do is we're going to replace Y with Y
and X with negative x now remember I
like to always when I'm doing the
substitutions I like to put them in
parenthesis so now we've got a negative
to an odd power which is negative and so
this is going to give us a negative two
x to the fifth and a negative times a
negative is a positive does that look
like a original equation no okay last
one the origin we're going to make them
both negative so here we have replace Y
with negative Y X with negative x and
let's simplify so we have negative Y
this came out to negative 2x to the
fifth because a negative to an odd power
and negative times a negative is a
positive and if we multiply through by
negative one this is going to give us
positive y equals 2x to the fifth minus
ax which you can see is the same as the
original one so we know it's a respect
to the origin it's a 180 degree rotation
about the origin okay see if you can do
this last example here we've got six
plus x times y to the fourth power
equals zero and while you're doing that
if you're new to the channel and we're
meeting for the first time my name is
Mario of Mario's math tutoring and my
goal for this channel is really to help
you to make learning math less stressful
so you can raise your grade pass your
class and go on and pursue your dreams
so I'm a full time math tutor I work
with students every day in my local area
helping them with their math and I try
to take what I learn about what helps
students the best with these different
types of problems in these different
types of math classes and distill it
down and put it into these lessons on
YouTube here so that you can benefit
from my tutoring as well so that's
something that you're interested in
check out more math videos on my Mario's
math tutoring YouTube channel but let's
go through this last example together
let's start off of doing the x-axis
symmetry test so if we replace X with X
Y with negative Y let's see a negative
to an even power is positive so that one
looks like it's giving us back the
original equation so it looks like this
is symmetric with respect to the x axis
let's check the other ones though as
well so here if we do the y axis test
we're going to replace X with negative x
Y with positive Y and here you can see Y
to the fourth is going to be Y to the
4th times negative x is negative x Y to
the 4th does that look like the original
no because we have this minus sign here
so it's not symmetric with respect to
the y axis how about the origin here
we're making both the X and the y the
opposite and so you can see a negative
to an even power that's positive Y to
the 4th times a negative x and if we
simplify here this is 6 minus XY to the
4th does that look like the original no
we have that minus here again so it
looks like it's just x-axis symmetry the
other thing that you oftentimes learn
when you're learning about these
algebraic symmetry tests is this idea
this concept of even functions and odd
functions so I'll link up to my video on
even and odd functions and how to tell
which one it is in that video right
there so follow me to that video and
we'll dive into that